Africa was once populated by hundreds of
thousands of rhinoceroses but today the
species is almost extinct Africa's
national parks have had to ramp up
security because increasingly poachers
are heavily armed wildlife preservation
is turning into a war these ranges in
South Africa's Kruger National Park
don't want to be recognized out of
concern for their family's safety ranges
we used to focus more on environmental
stuff and and with time ADA seemed to
have been a switch of us being more
military in some in some ways like you
can see I'm having a raffle when range
is managed to arrest poachers out
hunting rhinos listen to court most of
them a young man I destroy their own
lives I mean they get to go home after
10 or 20 or 30 years leaving the family
devastated with absolutely no income
because to the best of our knowledge the
crime bosses then don't don't worry
about the family the men many of whom
come from Mozambique receive about five
hundred dollars for a successful hunt
that's a lot for the impoverished people
here a desire for some kind of affluence
leads these people to take risks they
can barely begin to calculate a lot of
them spend their earnings in one weekend
then they go back out hunting till they
eventually get caught
lawyer Mike none yani often defends
young poachers around 400 of them are
tried in the court every year because it
was Rita the a childís indicates whether
they deal a state can approach anyone
looking at their educational background
and their reasoning capacity they tell
them there's a lot of money they don't
tell them about the risk involved so I
would say they are victims aside the
real profits are made by the ivory
smugglers and Africa's wildlife is
rapidly disappearing if the killing
continues there'll be no more wild
elephants and rhinoceroses left there by
the middle of this century